the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
your social medias
please make sure you're subscribed to
the youtube channel
that community i mean i'm not sure when
this episode episode's gonna come out
but we're
like we started at a thousand people
we're at a hundred thousand in a year
i don't again i don't know if that's
good progress but man i [ __ ] feel
like it is i don't know what everybody
else is out there doing
but i'm keeping my goddamn head down i'm
minding my [ __ ] business i'm doing my
own [ __ ] over here
and a hundred thousand of you on along
for the ride thank you so much if you
gotta have more
hit up the patreon we're doing an
episode a week we're not giving you some
30 minute [ __ ] we're doing
about an hour plus every week and it's
the honeydew
with y'all just like this show but i'm
highlighting the lowlights with y'all
it's five bucks a month
i know that's a lot of money for some
people right now if you sign up for a
year you'll get a month free
and you can now get the honeydew a day
early
ad free that's on a monday uh at no
extra cost
for the rest of 2021 all right that's
we're doing
hit up that merch store night pants
nation continues to grow
i can't wait to get out there and see
you guys on that night pants nation tour
i'm going to do
and i just appreciate all your support
all right
all that said now um you guys know i
record here at the santa monica music
center we're working
with uh outreach through the arts uh
give back program working with at-risk
youth kids they're doing podcasts here
with the santa monica police department
obviously there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
uh in the last year
currently as well it'll always continue
and they're opening the narrative
together so i think it's really awesome
to help and give back
and when that gets out and done here
i'll be promoting that but i just wanted
to give you all
a heads up about it all right that is it
the honeydewpodcast.com
that's the website for the honeydew and
uh if you're new here welcome
if you're back welcome back you guys
know we do here we highlight the
lowlights
it's it's i'll be honest it's a
beautiful [ __ ] show is really what it is
and uh these are the stories behind the
storytellers
very excited to have this guest on here
a very old friend of mine first time
here on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome sarah the audio
thank you for having me it's been a
pleasure to catch up with you before
i know we probably should have been
recording but it's been awesome to see
you
the last time i saw you you were an
expecting mom
oh and you were huge sarah
like i know your face everything looked
normal and then you're just like this
now you're like my face did not my nose
was swollen my lips were swollen like i
look at videos of myself and i'm like it
looks like i ate
myself like i ate my face i gained
65 pounds you know i lost 27 of them on
the table when he was born
like so i lost basically half the weight
when he came out he was 10 pounds on the
nose he was just a giant
giant baby like it was so uncomfortable
and hard
but then like i mean i've lost like i
weigh less now than i did before i was
pregnant i mean it was like oh thanks
but it took you know like whenever dona
looks good on you girl
yeah i tell you what like being able to
work from home you can go on walks and
like
you know do all kinds of things take
care of yourself live a little better
yeah get some vitamin d sunshine take
him out he just started walking so we're
always in the backyard and
and when they say like you you lose
weight because you're chasing a baby
around it's so true because like i'll be
trying to eat but then he wants to eat
what i'm eating like
you just eat everything goes slower in
the food process because you're trying
to get food in them
and yourself and i'm like i don't even
know if i did eat something you know and
so
isn't it amazing too like you just blink
and you're like it's 5
30. oh i i love when people are like
you're never going to sleep and i'm like
i get probably 10 hours of sleep a night
but it's not enough it doesn't matter
yeah i didn't get that still
tired well now you know like we go to i
mean i will go to bed at like nine
o'clock and it feels so good
and he'll sleep from seven to seven
now so it's so nice right now but he's
kind of transitioning into this one nap
territory so this has been a lot of fun
it's a lot going on with
walking and napping we have a um thing
my daughter and i
were curious about it i don't know if
it's a real thing that could be possibly
hereditary or not but
she is a straight-up night owl like i am
oh really she loves the night like i
like she keeps the comics hours i'm like
go to bed
i'm working on this bit dad i'm like go
to bed what time does she wake up
she'll get up well we have to go to
school right now finally thank god but
even with zoom it was 8 30 it started so
she would get up at like 8 15.
you know hair all over whatever ain't
nothing wrong i was like you can do that
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
while school's out now we got to be at
school
by like 8 30 so we're up at seven
um but she's she doesn't care she wants
us she just
don't want to miss anything i'm telling
you it's i wonder if it's a hereditary
thing because i've always been that way
too i'm not a morning person
i'll get up and do it be pleasant about
it but i come alive
you know that's the nighttime yeah i
mean comedians are like
uh tigers at the zoo like all day you go
to a zoo you ever see a tiger running
around
just laying around waiting to eat and
then at night they're like hey
what's up everybody so like that's i
mean
i i definitely think it's hereditary for
sure well
as we talk about life i'm excited to
talk about this because we're going to
do
near-death experiences which we have not
done on here as an episode
so ever um no i mean people certainly
shared a story but we haven't had
multiple
uh and you and i have a similar thing so
um
before we do plug everything you want
and then
we'll jump right oh i mean i'm just on
twitter and instagram that's like
the best place to find me i have a
youtube channel
sometimes i add little roast videos here
and there but it's all sara tiana sarah
with an h
tiana with the tiana very easy to find
my mom i have to give a shout out to my
mom her name is sue haynes she's
your biggest fan
uh she's what are you sewing right now
sue
she so when i would go on the road my
mom would make cat bandanas and dog bow
ties
and um and so she sits at home and she
still makes off you realize that your
mom
was pre-coveted on cats before cove
whatever [ __ ] what do you mean
she wear a little bandanna you could put
it right up
put it right up she did make me a lot of
masks
early on which is very helpful my mom's
a great seamstress
if you need a bow tie or a bandana for
your cat or dog
it's at catbandanna.com
all spelled out d-o-t-com on instagram
and then catbandanna.com you can order
on the website there's lots of fun ones
we can actually make our own fabric now
so we could take your honeydew logo we
could make some honeydew bandanas i told
my daughter we could get a puppy
i would love a honeydew bandana i will
make
i will make some of that fabric you know
what i love about your mom
she used to tell me all the time she
would listen to the craft feast and i'm
like how in the hell is your mama craft
face fan
and then she loved your episode but you
would tell me oh you guys talked about
me
like yeah yeah i told the story about
you and i yeah
yeah oh yeah we're still on it yeah my
mom would text me anytime you would
bring me up on the podcast and it always
made me feel so good
hey that she was listening and b that
you were saying nice things about me
come on that's always nice things about
so funny yeah so she's
your biggest fan and she sits in her
sewing room and like
as she's making quilts for the baby now
or whatever she's working on like she's
always listening to your show so
you're doing a really good job if oh
thank you sue your broad range of fans
can go from people like me to you know
yeah that's impressive it is i'm i'm
pleasantly surprised yeah yeah um real
quick
has your mom met your son yet oh yes
okay so you're able to do that
yes okay good she actually got to me so
he was born february 25th and she came
out
a week later and uh so yeah
two weeks later right before the
lockdown so she actually left
on march 12th when everything was
locking down yeah
so she got to meet him then and then we
all got vaccinated so we had like a big
vaccination party
for easter so she came out to visit and
then just
last week i went home to visit my dad
because he turned 70.
wow with me and then like here we are
yeah here we are
yeah so let's talk about near death
okay tiana yeah it's so funny because i
i was thinking about this story the
other day because
before i had a kid before i had anything
to lose
i always thought the best way to go
would be in a plane crash
because hear me out okay i
i'm about to tell a story about almost
dying in one but i know you pass out
you know so i'll be passed out you might
not be high enough you might just be
able to take them
that's true hopefully you're up in the
air and then you just crack
statistically rarely does it happen up
there it's take off and land just so you
know
take off and land it your ass is going
to be awake i'm hoping that it would be
where i would pass out
probably from fear anyway i should be in
first class i'll probably be drinking
and then my family would get all this
money from the airline so i'm like oh
everybody wins
in that scenario and every
every screaming passenger on board the
sounds would be horrific
but before i had a baby i was like
there's not a lot of cleanup here you
know what i mean like there's no orphan
left behind there's no
husband left behind you know what i mean
but now that i have one i'm like oh man
i'm so glad you go from nothing to lose
yes to everything
and like even just taking him on a plane
home last week you know without
his dad i was like terrified you know
the same thing you know you think of
kobe you're like i don't want to split
the fam i just want us to always all
travel together
forever um so that was like you know
mentally challenging but yes so
i was going to tell you a story about
being on a military tour
so i was on an all-female military tour
through the south pacific
so we had we started here's this this
would have probably been
2000 2009
yeah 2009 probably uh so we started in
hawaii
like doing shows at pearl harbor then we
went down to the marshall islands
then we went to japan and then we came
to singapore
damn uh yeah so we were doing uh oh no
we went to okinawa and then
singapore and um so we were on a flight
a military flight we're in a c-130
and the 130s are the ones that are
carrying the tanks and the humvee that's
your cargo plane
so but this was a passenger like
normally in a c-130 you would be sitting
on the sides of the plane and there
would be nothing in the middle except
for cargo facing each other
this one there were about 10 rows
towards the front of the plane
that were 10 people long so there's
basically like 100 people on the plane
but like
the rows aren't like a regular airplane
where there's two three two or whatever
there would be uh you know four four
four or something
peanuts on them yeah no there's no
flight attendant
you know chase i got an allergy i just
want to make sure you don't
actually yeah so this one all the cargo
is behind us
you know that's a [ __ ] like they're like
they're like a building
yes it's a very like you are not going
to hit your head on the ceiling
you know you can stand up and move
around do you remember what's in there
with you
other than cargo is there any equipment
or is it just
all cool i mean everything's under a
tarp and it's tied up so
and you're just sitting in front of that
yes we're sitting in front of that
um there's airmen to the right of me
there's lots of contractors on the plane
going to diego garcia diego garcia is
an island that the u.s military
populates that we got in vietnam
so it's more just like it's like an
access point between it kind of keeps an
eye on the sky like the marshall islands
do
between us and japan after pearl harbor
they're like you know what why don't we
just stay here and keep an eye up top
anything flying overhead so so
uh we were going there to do a show it
was me
april macy who i just i just talked to
her about this the other day so that's
what made me remember it
like shane and tosh melinda hill like
there's
all these girls and so we get up to like
30 000 feet and they go oh you can take
out your laptops now or whatever
so we take out we're starting to take
out our stuff and our
ipods and my ears start popping really
bad and i can't like
clear my ear you know like where you're
just like
i can't and then i start seeing spots
and i'm just like
starting to get dizzy and i can tell i'm
starting to pass out and i'm like
have you ever passed out prior to this
no okay not that i
but you can tell you're going i'm like
yeah you're just confused as to why
you're feeling all this you know
and then i just start hearing from all
these
alarms start going off and the air masks
pop out of the seat
in front of us so they because again the
ceilings are so high they can't come
from the ceiling so they come out of the
seat
in front of you basically like the
headrest okay
and you're just you're in a daze because
again you're passing out
and this guy comes running from behind
from the back of the plane
and he's like take it down take it down
take it down
and all of a sudden you feel the plane
just start going like nose diving and
you're
like you're trying so then the airman
next to me puts my
face mask on my my oxygen mask because
i'm a child and you have to put yours on
first and then you can help the child
next to you
are you just like jelly over there just
like what the [ __ ] yeah as soon as you
get a little oxygen then all of a sudden
you're kind of coming too
so you're a little bit more like pumping
some oxygen it is okay yes and like
you pull it but it doesn't like you go
to put it on and it doesn't you have to
snap it and you're afraid
i'm like don't snap it it's going to
snap the oxygen cord but that's what
it's just attached to something and you
have to pull it really hard
and you get it on and then you can feel
the plane diving they open up the
the captain's doors the pilot's doors
all the
the two pilots and whoever else is in
the pilot's cabin are standing up
they're wearing these huge gas masks
what the [ __ ] who's
lying this thing flipping through a book
and i'm like what the [ __ ] you're
ordering lunch man i'm [ __ ]
a little hungry back here man you're
like what
is happening you know you're like am i
even through a
book my uncle i told this story to my
uncle who's a two-star general who flew
in vietnam he's like
you know uh he hates pilots now because
it's so easy back then they had to do
like long division
yeah he's like my day you know you know
now the plane just flies exactly so he's
like oh they're going through a
checklist and i'm like
no [ __ ] they were looking stuff up
you know and they were they were
flipping pages and then they you know
like
how do you spell emergency
so yeah so all of a sudden
we basically research why is the door
open or why are they facing
you guys the airman next to me who i put
my mask on
grabs my hands and i notice that he's
crying and i'm like
it's like you know if you're on a plane
and you see the flight attendants if
they're calm
i'm calm i know what they're the fact
that he was not calm
i was like that's it and people always
ask me like
what were you thinking about when
because you're like okay i'm gonna die
uh all i could think about was
no one knows where i am except for the
government the only people who know
because when you go on a military tour
everything that you dictate to your
families in past tense no one can know
where you're going
or when you're going to be there for
security reasons so when you get to
singapore you're like
oh we had a great we were having such a
great time in the marshall islands
this is what it looked like you know but
they don't know where you are now
and so i'm like uh pat tillman had
recently happened i was really on edge
about that
and you know i'm a hundred miles above
the indian ocean
and no one knows where i am and so i'm
like they can tell my arm is blaring in
your ears yeah and all i can think about
is they can tell my family anything they
want
is my family gonna know what really
happened is
anybody gonna understand you know like
because obviously when there are
celebrities on board or quote unquote
you know
comedians like that's a really bad look
for the military and the project
and so yeah and then all of a sudden
like the plane flattened out
because basically what happened was we
lost cabin pressure we lost oxygen
so when you're on a plane you know they
seal the plane with cabin pressure you
breathe the oxygen from the plane not
the outside air because there's not a
lot of oxygen up that high
it's like when you climb everest you
usually need oxygen
so they were diving to 10 000 feet so
that we could breathe outside air
which and and i remember because that
greek plane had crashed
like a little while i don't remember
when that greek plane crashed but
basically
everybody on the plane they lost cabin
pressure everybody on the plane passed
out
and the plane just flew until it crashed
into a mountain
and so i was just like and all of this
stuff is stuff i realized once we got on
the ground
but in the moment you're just like what
is going on like i'm so confused and
so we got to 10 000 feet they turned
back around we went back to singapore
we get on the ground we can barely walk
because our equilibrium is so thrown off
because of our ears and they go
just sit here we'll get you guys another
plane in like an hour and i go you can
keep that to your [ __ ] self
i'm going home and all the other girls
were like
okay yeah we're doing that too because i
think they were you know and i was just
like
i that was like my 12th rodeo and i was
like no thanks
i'm going back to the you guys we'll do
this another day
and so everything was fine after that
we stayed in singapore for a couple days
and then went home
did anyone scream did you hear anybody
oh yeah people were screaming
crying like a lot of people had a tough
time
breathing even when we got on the ground
i think some people had
a tough time getting their masks on you
know it's so crazy like you hear those
descriptions
over and over again on an airplane and
then it actually happens and you're like
what do i do you know
it's no matter how many times you hear
about how to put on an oxygen mask it's
like
still difficult to remember how to do it
when you're passing out
crying yeah yeah and that's that's
what really hit me you know and then um
yeah april actually sent me a picture
from the plane so i'll say i'll share it
with you if you want to
yeah show people yeah so you did they
listen did they make you they let you
stay that night
yeah yeah we didn't go we did not go
back to diego garcia we stayed in
singapore
though or they just canceled that it was
our last show anyway
so it was the end of the tour i think we
might have done another show in
singapore for the
uh contractors there just because we
were already there and then
we just spent the rest of the time in
the country well that that's one of my
favorite countries in the world it's
like one of the coolest countries i've
ever been to so
it was fine to just hang out there and
did you ever ask them what they were
looking
at in the book or what they were really
doing it is a checklist
so that is what they're going through
they have to go through a check like
like in
in any emergency even on the airplane
like
i don't know if you watch the sully
movie but they
open up a book for a checklist whenever
something happens and so there is
a list of things that you have to do and
and he didn't go by that list
that was the whole point of sully had to
just react because there wasn't enough
time
um to make a turn or go to this airport
or do whatever you know so
uh so yeah so they have to go through a
checklist which is
you know whatever the checklist is but
ultimately dive to ten thousand feet and
get everybody outside air damn yeah and
then
from there when everyone gets outside
air then take it down and land it
yeah so there you know there's nothing
wrong with the plane they just [ __ ] up
with the cabin pressure
yeah it was just the cabin pressure yeah
there's nothing with the engines there
was nothing
it's a building you're trying to fly out
in the sky like that's not an easy thing
to do
no no no no no like a c17 is actually a
little bit bigger but like a c-130 is
still like
a ginormous plane it's like bigger than
any regular commercial flight you would
be on and
carrying who knows what you know the
back of it can open and close you know
so
like you feel like all right we're at
ten thousand feet just open up the back
operation don't let me pass out
yeah so let's take a quick break and
tell you about
my favorite headphones raycons whether
it's for work
or play a lot of us are going to be on
the move again this summer so
my advice to you take your raycons with
you whether you're listening to spotify
or the honeydew podcast a pair of raycom
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference you get crisp
powerful beats at half the price
of other premium audio brands raycons
look great
and feel even better they come in a
range of cool colors and with
customizable gel tips included
for a comfortable in-ear fit look i
don't know i got a weird inner ear i can
never find the gel tips to fit raycons
are money i take them everywhere i take
them when i travel
when i fly when i exercise i've been
telling all the comics they're all
talking about
their their other earbuds falling out or
whatever it is
i told them don't spend all that money
buy some raycons
their money all right raycons are built
to go wherever you go and with
quick and seamless bluetooth pairing and
a compact charging case and i'm telling
you
they stay charged in that case forever
i've had mine in the car when i drive
around for days i grab and they're still
charged up to go so listen
up raycon's offering 15 off all their
products from my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon.com
honeydew there you'll get 15 off your
entire raycon order and it's such a good
deal you want to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15 percent off at byraycon.com
honeydew by raycon.com honeydew
our next sponsor is mint mobile now
after years of fine print contracts
and get ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch all right so when i first heard
that mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month i thought
what's the catch but after speaking with
them and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one
mint mobile's secret sauce is that
they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only so
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you
in the form of mystery fees instead mint
just passes on sweet savings
direct to you all right so for people
looking for extra savings like myself
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network you can
use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan and keep your
same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven-day money-back
guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting just
15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com honeydew that's
mint mobile.com
honeydew cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month
at mintmobile.com honeydew
i've been there before yeah so tell me
you you said you i told this story on
the craft feast a long time ago and i've
probably mentioned it but it's
it's i'll share it with you because uh
it was a very similar experience
in that it was a military tour
it was a gig it was a military show it's
not a tour
i'll take that back you were on a tour
military
i believe it's called i i don't know i'm
wrong a lot but i think it's the san
marcos islands you go up here to
ventura harbor there's a little base
right there oh yeah
and then you just take like a 20-minute
flight out to like towards the channel
island exactly
that's exactly right and they were
telling us it's weird out there where
it's it's got its own like environment
almost it's overcast
it's just out in the ocean it's funky
and nasty and uh very
um you know temperamental
yes well set so we're on this show
uh daryl wright vodka time uh three-tier
community
car fan nascar fan the right turn he
used to have a podcast
um that he was on it i was on it a few
other comedians are on it
and um we're you know they weigh you
first and they weigh your [ __ ] to make
sure you know everybody's got to get on
the scale there's no lying about like
i'm 200 pounds like 2 2
27 [ __ ] they're like so they
have to push yeah
way on there yeah yeah you gotta get
hold on the wing bro it's only 20
minutes
so um we're getting on and for this
flight it's unexpectedly packed
um they don't usually fly this many
people over but they're just putting
everybody on to get over
and uh what's the size of what kind of
plane is it that's a small
thing man it's just we got propellers
okay
and it's a rickety old ass military
plane
you know it's like it's the larry king
of flames it's the larry king
it's the barry king of planes you don't
even know who that is you know what i
mean
it's a knock off larry king it's a knock
all flare kick
sure sure so we're getting on and
there's one guy from the military who's
with us he's sort of our guide to take
us over and stuff
and uh his wife's coming with us and
we're small talking as we're getting on
the plane
and i see a tire and it looks [ __ ]
flat i'm like god that tire looks flat
like is that
and she's like you're right it does that
really does look flat he's like oh we're
fine we
all get on the plane and it's just like
two two by two you know it's not a huge
one but there's maybe
a couple dozen people on this thing
right and
um it's got some cooks and stuff who
work on the island and they park there
and they fight and every day this is
their commute they fly over
fly back they cook for the right every
day
okay so it's this old ass rickety plane
and we're and daryl is scared to death
of flying as it is and i'm not at the
time
and um i'm even like this [ __ ]
looks like a junkyard plane like this
rolled out of sanford son you know like
what is this yeah and it's got
like brown marks and stain like this
dirt and they're like nah i had an
electrical fire
that's just the house like oh my god but
now they know that
daryl's scared we wiped it off everyone
is piling on
scare the [ __ ] guy that's scared to
fly right
and they're like uh you know a couple
weeks ago we had to belly land this and
there was like what
he's like the gear wouldn't come down we
had to slide this on the grass and i'm
like daryl that would care to play like
don't stop
we wouldn't be honest but it starts
going and you're
like and you can hear every squeak
you know what i mean and i'm looking out
the window like oh god
oh god and i'm not scared to fly now
we're up 20 minutes
we're good but like you said the flight
attendant cause there was one
she's on this little jumper seat in the
back and all of a sudden
she stands up and she hustles to the
front like she's been called
okay and she opens that little door and
she shuts it and she comes out
oh god and this chick should never play
poker
okay it was all over her death it looked
like i mean she walked in
a flight and said it walked out like the
grim reaper with the
sickle she might as well walk back and
everyone took notice now
there's only a handful of us for the
show everyone else on there
is a seasoned veteran on these planes
they're doing this all the time
so they don't give a [ __ ] well when they
saw her you could feel
and see everyone change and we're like
what the [ __ ] going on
and then it's like we're like what is
going on and i guess it's crazy windy
out
and we're getting caught up in this wind
okay and it's it's a rough thing and
daryl's like oh my god and you know
people are still joking a little bit
and then the [ __ ] jokes stop when she
sits back down and i see the guy next to
me goes hey is everything all right and
she goes
mm-hmm and i was like oh that is i've
seen i've heard that um
i've been in relationships because i've
been in bad relationships
i did something wrong i'll find out
later yeah hopefully
and um the [ __ ] door
from the cockpit flies open and
you can see you know they're on a
smaller plane
you can see the pilot in the co-pi you
can see the front of the plane
but you don't see the ocean that we're
flying over you see like
land and like what the [ __ ] is going on
and the plane
is now sideways like this they're trying
to bring us in for landing and it gets
caught sideways
so as we're sitting back here we're now
looking out the front we're facing this
way the plane's over here
and they're trying to bring it around to
bring us down on this landing pad
everyone starts people are screaming
okay i knew it was real when i saw the
people
that do it all the time when they
gripped their seat and i saw the white
in their knuckles i was like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] like it's real yeah
and everyone's looking at each other and
people are screaming
and the guy spins this [ __ ] thing
around and i've been on planes before
where they were
on a descent and then i guess the gate
wasn't available and then they
yes and you're like [ __ ] yeah there's
another plane in the runway
another hour but i'm wondering why we're
not doing that
why are we not but we're too low to do
it
okay and we [ __ ] he he pulls us back
and we hit the runway and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] tire
you hear this pop and we hit hard as
[ __ ] and it's just
bouncing and guy next to me he's just
going
one he just can't help himself he's
counting the bounces and i was like shut
the [ __ ] up
and we hit and it skids and it skids to
the edge of this [ __ ] runway i mean
the edge it's the cliff over there i was
gonna say what's at the end of the road
more ocean but down down oh god and
everyone gets off it is silent and they
get out
and we can't talk about anything but
what just happened yeah of course
and then we all get to the show and
every comedian doesn't want to be a hack
but we can't
not talk about what just [ __ ]
happened so we all do a show and we're
talking about like how horrific it was
and i'm just like i'm scared to death to
fly
back like i'll robin say hi
so after the show the guys come over to
us and they're like
listen man today was no joke we're like
yeah we [ __ ] know he's like no you
don't know man like that was we're like
no we got it we got it we heard the
screams
we realized that [ __ ] was real i was
like holy [ __ ] we got to fly back like
we got to fly back and i just
that was the most terrifying flight i've
ever been on because you spend the night
over there and then you fly the next day
the next morning back
on that rickety [ __ ] plane back why
do you have to fly back why can't you
take a boat back
i mean the flight was 20 minutes i don't
know how long it would take on a boat
probably an
hour or so well that's worth the hour
they just didn't
i'm not joking when i tell you there was
a wrecked plane on the
i swear to god like a little little
cessna on the [ __ ] rocks
that we flew over i'm not kidding you um
they say that they do
testing military testing on this island
and [ __ ] like it was a really
weird [ __ ] thing altogether they'd be
testing my patience and that was
that was the last that was the last
military gig i got on a flight for i'll
drive to san diego anytime yeah
man no more so what was the actual issue
was it just the wind and the wind caught
us out in that
like little vortex and we were coming
down it [ __ ] the whole plane up but it
also seems like if the
plane is full like normally it wouldn't
be full so i would understand why
the plane could get caught in the wind
but if it's heavier i'm surprised that
it did
i'm guessing the pilots weren't the best
up there either
i mean if they landed that thing with
one wheel they landed
so then we went up in the control tower
when we were leaving we go up in the
control tower i'm like no no we got to
talk to this guy up here
i'm like tell us what happened he's like
all right here's what happened he's like
when you normally come in
it's he's like a a ruler in front of you
he's showing us the landing strip and
he's like
you normally hit at d and then you stop
at b
he's like you guys hit it c and you
stopped
after a like i was like we really
worried he's like you guys are really
that it was that bad yeah we're like
holding that close
[ __ ] oh my god
so i know you said you had another one
i've got another near death too but it's
not a plane
no i mean i won i definitely like i
remember i told you
about my first trip to iraq in 2005
that was my first military tour saddam
was still alive at the time
you told me about the fish and all that
stuff and the fish in his lake
well that was the lake in baghdad that
surrounded the compound
at biop it was like they're all these
like giant carp there and they would
just like eat
anything like you could feed them eggs
and they're like you know
and you know saddam's people are
starving but he told them that they were
magic fish and if
they caught the fish and ate it the fish
would tell him so like no one would eat
the fish
anyway it was like it was quite it was
quite the process
and at the time it was a very
until i've been on like so many tours
now i realize how dangerous that tour
was
it was like because we were still doing
um
convoys and i don't know if you've ever
been on a military convoy but basically
it's like just a ton of humvees like
whenever they have to take
supplies from one base to another they
would drive in a convoy
and that's just one big line of military
vehicles
and then there would be two humvees that
circle the convoy
to protect it so they're just like these
two little
buzzing bees that go up and down and
around the convoy
and the convoy would take up so if
there's two lanes on the freeway
in you know in iraq they would take it
they would just drive down the middle
lane and then the other hummers would go
up and around it
so it would back up traffic like the
locals would be so upset and they would
drive to the other side of the freeway
to go around it
like full on head-on yes like
but anyway that's their own issue but
like i can understand how that would be
very frustrating to be stuck behind sure
and we would be in like these
like like you'd open up the door for the
escalade and the windows would be like
two inches thick you know i mean this is
what the presidents would ride in
and when you're when you go overseas as
a comedian you're given
you have to be given a rank and a
clearance so we're given what's called i
believe it's a gs
14 which is basically a full bird
colonel which is right
before general so and my uncle at the
time was a fulbright colonel he hadn't
become a general yet and so
he was the one telling me all this stuff
because you have to get a rank so that
you can get on the planes
you're a colonel officially when you're
well that's your rank
right technically you're still a
civilian you know you're not i'm not
allowed to have a weapon or whatever but
i'm allowed
into certain not out there take cover
yeah
you're allowed yeah i mean i would
i'm not afraid to get my hands dirty i
was the first woman that had been over
there
that would like carry her own bag it was
just like
i was like i would wear like boots and
like all this
tactical gear and then when we get to
the show i changed into heels and put on
perfume and i brought a portable curling
iron so that
i could like look present because i'm
like i know what i'm here for you know
what i mean
here because they just love my jokes
about lieutenants
you know so uh i would let them i would
like rub my perfume on their clothes
like whatever
just winning hearts and minds like
anything i could do and
the whole reason i even wanted to go
over there no they're all
they're all back at the bunk sniffing
your [ __ ] perfume
this is also you know let's see this is
quiet tonight
everybody's in there it's quiet tonight
yes also i mean i'm 43 now but in my 20s
i was a little bit more of a looker
still are so
thank you so i knew what i was doing
over there
and we had a great time you know and i
and a big part of the reason i wanted to
go
was um because when i was growing up in
high school we had recruiters in my high
school every day at lunch
i knew a lot of like the brigade from my
hometown was in iraq i was trying to get
to see them the whole time they were in
the green zone it was a really tough
zone to be in
we had a show there uh one of the days
that i was over there
and we were gonna go but then there
that road got blown up that day and we
couldn't go it was just like too
dangerous
and i was really bummed because i found
out like six months later that they had
ordered like all this
like barbecue to to give
and like to have you know i was like oh
it was just like so depressing but
so i was like oh they probably don't
even know that i'm from calhoun you know
and um
they did they were like sitting there
waiting and then like
five minutes after the show was supposed
to start somebody just put a chris rock
dvd in and i was like
i mean you'd probably they should
probably they would have wanted to watch
chris rock more than me so like i'm sure
it was fine but
it was kind of a bummer but anyway by
the time
we got to biop we were um
we had just done a show for special
forces which is like
the arm like the special forces are like
you can't take any video you can't take
pictures of them like you can't
it was the only show that we did they
were they lived in
saddam's girlfriend's mansion
and it had this cool pool it had
like all the stuff like they were it was
the only show we did where no one had a
weapon
because they don't need weapons to kill
you
like yeah they can kill you with their
finger and i'm like what else can you do
with that
but i didn't say that i said that at the
show
and then um i remember like one of the
captains like taking me into this room
and he's like do you want to hear
something cool i'm like okay
and it's like this like room where
they're like lit they're
commanding another group that's like out
and they were like raiding a house and
so he's like isn't that and i'm like i i
don't want to hear people screaming
you know anyway so we're in the green
zone
it's like they're at our streets here
they're just coming into somebody's
house yeah
this is this lady getting all mad at it
it's like a 9-1-1 operator being like
listen to this
yeah yeah there's a fire and they're
trapped inside
isn't that hilarious you're like not
really actually that's not
that's not exactly entertaining but i
guess you've been here a while so it
might be to you
uh so anyway we were
uh we were staying in one of uh saddam's
hunting lodge is where we were staying
holy hunt over there exactly it was just
on the lake
people it was called his hunting lodge
but it was like everything is gold and
there's it's like a castle
or a man i don't even know and um
i'm like where is he even being held and
they're like we can't tell you that and
then they would
just like like point like when we were
flying overhead so
at the time we were flying in blackhawk
helicopters because that's the easiest
and fastest way to get from base to base
and
we were going to uh i was over there
with a group called comics on duty and
they specialized in going to small bases
fobs which are called forward operating
bases which means
there's all these giant bases like biop
which is uh baghdad international
airport which was the hub
right that's probably where saddam was
being held and
the the the main base
um supplies the fobs the fob supply the
patrol bases the patrol bases are like
14 guys
so a fob is like where the patrol base
guys will come and kind of like relax
for a day get new supplies and head back
out into the field
so we would be performing at fobs
because a patrol base is never in a
set location so there would be like 100
200 guys at some of these bases
sometimes there'd be
800 you know so we would be flying to
all these little bases that never got
entertainment that was our whole goal
and so to get there we would have to fly
on blackhawks and blackhawks always
fly in twos so that they can protect
each other and we had this guy
that that picked us up in baghdad his
name was major hater
and everybody called him major hated
because
he was kind of a dork and like one of
those guys who is like
a high-ranking officer because he was
good in school
you know not because he was good with
the web but very important in the
military you know what i mean those guys
are very essential
they get made fun of but they're
incredibly important very excited to
tell you about this next sponsor babel
is with us guys this summer get the most
out of your travels abroad by learning
the language of your destination with
babel babel is the number one selling
language
learning app from ordering in
restaurants or asking for directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language
addictively fun and easy and with
bite-sized lessons
you can actually use in real world
babble is a
can't miss travel essential all right so
here's the deal i went to mexico a few
months ago
i didn't know what the hell they were
saying i took spanish in whatever 8th
9th 10th 11th grade but it was proper
spanish
i wasn't doing good in proper english so
i knew i wasn't doing good in proper
spanish
i wanted conversational spanish i went
on babel before they were sponsored
bought a year of babble and i've been
taking spanish lessons and i love it you
go through the lesson
then they do a review after it you have
it in male and female voices
it's fantastic i love it so they're
15-minute lessons all right and they
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go so unlike the
infamous language classes you took in
high school like me
babel designs their courses with
practical real-world
conversations in mind things you'll get
to use in everyday life and that's what
i picked i pick conversational spanish
all right
other language learning apps they use ai
for their lessons plans but babel's
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven
to be effective alright so with babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent you can imagine
what i sound like repeating the spanish
words that happen that app's like i
don't know
what you're saying bro there are so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes so
here's what you got to do
right now all right when you purchase a
three-month babble you'll get an
additional three months for free so
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-com
code honeydew for an extra three months
free our next sponsor is freshly now
dinner time can be chaotic but with
freshly
it's easy their chefs take care of your
meals a few nights a week and take the
pressure off you
freshly offered chef made
nutrient-packed delicious meals
delivered fresh to your door there is no
cooking required all right
grocery shopping and cooking can be a
pain especially right now
and with freshly you don't have to your
meals arrive
cooked and fresh every week so you can
keep your fridge stocked
and skip the trip to the store ordering
is easy all right you visit
freshly.com and you can choose from over
30 delicious
satisfying better for you meals like
steak peppercorns sausage baked penne or
their chicken pesto bowl which is one of
my favorites freshly can fit your
lifestyle with a variety of plans and
meals to pick from that work for your
dietary needs
preferences taste and family size and
now
my listeners can try freshly for just
six dollars and sixteen
cents per meal come on that's cheaper
than fast food
all right stop searching the internet
for healthy food near me every night and
start
living life freshly your meals are
always delivered fresh they're never
frozen
and they are ready to heat and enjoy in
just three minutes with new meals added
each week
freshly brings the convenience of chef
made nutritionist
designed classics right to your kitchen
look you know me i'm a single parent
my daughter's a super picky eater i just
need to eat stuff i'm over there making
two meals a lot all right so this is
perfect for me i need to eat healthy
i want to eat quick i'm out back doing
shows now instead of running
on the way home after a midnight spot or
an 11 o'clock spot
hitting mcdonald's or whatever i've got
freshly in the freezer all right so
right now freshly is offering my
listeners 40
off your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com
honeydew stop stressing about dinner go
to freshly.com
honeydew for 40 off your first two
orders
that's freshly.com honeydew
for forty dollars off your first two
orders
now let's get back to the duke and we're
like
so we're up flying above bad dad we're
going to
um i think we're going to a hospital to
perform
and we're sitting there you're like
looking down because you have to fly low
to the ground too because
they have to watch the ground they're
basically you're sitting in the
in a blackhawk have you ever been a
blackhawk you're sitting in a blackhawk
the doors are both open there's one guy
there's a guy hanging outside of each
door
with a weapon scanning the ground and
all they do is scan the whole time
both they're just watching out for each
other and you'll hear them if you're
wearing a headset you'll hear them say
you know blue nissan 3 o'clock and
everybody looks
you know and so all of a sudden
the flares go off on the on the
you can just smell so sulfur and you
just see two things flying out of the
blackhawk and you're like
what the [ __ ] and the major goes what
the hell was that
right and we're like you're in charge
you know like why do you not know
i'm not supposed to know you're the one
that's supposed to know and it turns out
that like
there was like a missile lock on us from
the ground and so they shoot the flares
off so that
the missile goes to the flare and not to
you how do they know that though
how do they know they're being targeted
or locked i think just like our
technology is a little bit better
you know and so or or they saw it
because they can see it coming in the
air and then like we made just like a
sharp right turn
and we landed pretty soon after that
yeah yeah
yeah and like ignorance is bliss right
i'm like i don't know what's going on
i'll just
have it on purpose yeah you wouldn't
that's the way to go
by the way yes that is the way it got
descent down where you pass out it's
what boom no you don't even have
what especially over
baghdad you know what i mean legend
instant legend
you know memorial brown like the rest of
those houses i'd be like
that flag's half-mast today for sarah
tiana right there guys
yeah that was like that was pretty
insane
and i remember like we we ended up
getting stuck because
at that hospital because and we had just
been stuck in another base for like
three days because of a sandstorm
when a sandstorm hits you can't fly
anywhere hey the
it's hard it's mostly because they can't
see the ground
so you can't watch out for things coming
up towards you and
it's like the conditions are too tough
to fly
so there was a sandstorm coming in and
they were like you're not going anywhere
you're sleeping in the hospital tonight
we're like
okay and it was like an abandoned
hospital that was like mostly
um just like an ops a special ops center
so and what are you in like a cot or
something like that yeah or yeah or you
would find a bet like wherever you could
find and then like last second they go
actually we're gonna take you back to
buyout because we have to give these
guys a ride to abu ghrib
and we're like what and we walk outside
and there are these four guys with hoods
over their heads
it's black as night outside they have
hoods over their heads
and they have glow sticks around their
necks in case they run in case they're
raving
it's gonna say run they can find them
and i go abu griff this is right after
abu grif happened
so i know that name and i'm like what
i'm like are we getting on the same
plane you all want us to get in the same
cutlass with these guys
i don't know if they're going to get my
jokes do they speak they speak english
yeah how much time how much time are
they doing i'm only doing 15. how much
time do those guys get
so yeah it was like it was like trippy
just like you got on a
flight with no they were on the other
side oh my god so we got on one they got
on the other one
but they but but they dropped us off
first so i didn't actually get to see
alba great but
that would have been cool because you
did see dudes with oh yeah [ __ ] hoods
over their heads
glow sticks around their necks and i was
like what is that and they're like
that's in case they run
i don't know if anybody out there is in
our us military but if you could please
let us know what is the u.s military
budget for glow sticks
just curious what we're spending on
closed decks
and smoke machines
yeah i just yeah i don't know somebody
out there has got to itemize that like
who the [ __ ] getting all these glow
sticks man
you know middle east oh well kevin's
having a birthday party
just take the ones off the prisoners we
got him already
that was so trippy like that is crazy it
was like a really trippy
experience yeah but i was like loved it
yeah you know
i mean i set off mike but i'll say it
i'm like you are the reason
i won't go do any military tour because
of that
i don't want to be shot at nothing no
i'll do military shows
here in the states and support the
troops because i support our troops but
i don't ever want to be on a black hawk
unless i'm being rescued from somewhere
for some
some good reason too yeah you know i
don't want to be i don't
i don't want to be the missing hiker you
know what i mean they gotta come air
lift me in that metal [ __ ] cage it
spins and [ __ ] i don't wanna ever be
that guy
no i mean yeah i guess i mean i would do
i would do it every day so would you go
back and do it now that you're a mom
now not going back now i'm saying right
now they say
sarah a month would you go be away from
your childhood a month
no i couldn't go what's the longest you
ever did before was it ever that long
i mean i think the longest i've ever
been gone is like
maybe two weeks okay would you go for
two weeks
that's i think so you would yeah maybe
when he
after he's like two you know like it'd
be really hard it would be really hard
um but i it's hard leaving your baby but
knowing what you know also
about how easily you could get shot down
or any of that
you don't have any yeah i mean i think
like if it
if we were in another full-fledged war
like we were back then i don't think
that i would go but like
now it's just like
i just they don't even like comedy as
much as they used to because now there's
netflix
and they can just watch all this
streaming stuff so like the last tour i
did was in korea
and tokyo and hardly anybody came out
because it's like you know they work 10
hours a day
6 days a week or 12 hours a day 6 days a
week like
going out at night is just exhaust
they'd rather just drink in their room
and watch netflix they can watch a
stand-up special there
you know so like i've been trying to get
a special off the ground that is just
comedians doing
their jokes about the military that i
can give to them
to watch on a streaming service because
i know that's what they
how they watch it now you know they
listen to podcasts like this
and and they watch comedy specials and
like that's how they get their
entertainment now they don't necessarily
need to see it live
and so i don't know i i think that would
be the only reason that i would be held
back from doing it was because i'd be
like i don't know how much they're into
it you know that's an interesting point
about
netflix and everything yeah yeah yeah
you have so much entertainment right
there on your phone you don't want
yeah yeah i mean i even i did that i
wrote on the show
rock the troops that the rock did at
pearl harbor and like
that was like so great for the people at
pearl harbor
and we they put it on tv and i don't
think it did that well because it's kind
of hard to watch a concert on tv you
know what i mean like
being there would be cool like seeing
those people live but with comedy
it's like it's much easier to watch that
on tv that's something that you can
that you don't always need to see live
and so
i i think that would be the only reason
that would hold me back
from doing it it's not like like i went
to afghanistan in 2011 and it was
right after we killed osama bin laden i
say we
because i pay taxes
and so i
thought we did a great job how quickly
after did you go
so he was i believe he was killed in may
and then i was there in august or june
so it was only like a month or two and
what was that like it was amazing but
you would ask the guys you'd be like
has your life changed and they're like
am i still here yeah
yeah they're like no big deal to us you
know
and you know i i really loved going as a
performer because i had
access access to so many generals into
so much brass and i could ask them a lot
of questions because i am a tax paying
civilian i do pay their salary
and i have a lot of questions i'd be
like how much is that how much gas is
going in there where are we getting that
gas from
and do the answer uh-huh yeah yeah yeah
anything that wasn't
like what's something you ask them that
and what's an answer you got that really
blew you away
uh about the aircraft carriers because i
would i asked about
i think we were in oman and i was asking
about the port in oman
and the aircraft carriers and
they they told me like how much money we
actually make on the aircraft carriers
because the air
we have 11 which is more than any other
country in the world
an aircraft carrier like
produces uh clean water so they can take
they can desalinate water
and make fresh water for local people
that's why like whenever
a tsunami happens or something a lot of
times our
medical ships or aircraft carriers will
go to that island because
it has a giant hospital it can make
clean water and it can you know help
but also whenever say we're bringing
we have to bring three airplanes over to
oman
so we have to ship them on an aircraft
carrier well we lease out
spots on that aircraft carrier to other
countries so that they can bring
cars over or it's almost like a fedex
truck
so we actually make money on shipping
because we bring stuff to other
countries that they need
and it's like all part of
you know the mail almost so i thought
that was really cool to learn that like
we're not just wasting money by having
these like floating ships do nothing
they're actually doing a service they're
not just out there
keeping security guards yeah they're
yeah but afghanistan we went to some
really incredible fobs you know where
like
like but that's also another near-death
experience that i had which was
we um were at a base um
outside of uh let's see where would we
have been we were in the helmand
province which was like southern
afghanistan mayonnaise brahma uh-huh
hellmuth
and you called me out on a mayonnaise
joke one time on the crab feast your mom
went to go to your mom go to the table
oh yeah
because i said something like do you
like mayonnaise or something we said
that when we were at the ducks game
and you you clowned me for it and now
look here's [ __ ] mayonnaise again
i can't stop with you because we were
both stoned
at the duck's game and we were sitting
in one of those lounges because i think
took me to the nicest [ __ ]
yeah i had a friend that worked for the
ducks and he hooked us up with all kinds
of cool stuff
and we were sitting in one of those
lounges eating free sandwiches
and then i was like you said something
about not liking mayonnaise and then you
just looked at me
like do you like mayonnaise and i just
started laughing
so hard because i'm like what
the way you asked it was like accusatory
but also
but also generous like
if you do i'll give you all of the
mayonnaise that i have
i'm accusing you yeah like first of all
it's gross that you like it but if you
do like it i'll give you all of mine
because thought
i was just like yes i do you know i just
i think it was also like a little bit of
the edible or whatever we had before
going in to really enjoy that game but
like
yeah that yes we're in the hillman
province
we're at a base that doesn't have
um bathrooms normally like you'll have
porta potties or whatever that you will
go in on a lot of these fobs because
you know they're just they're basically
said it's a camp you know and so they'll
set that up
in the middle of nowhere but this base
was so remote
uh they didn't have air conditioning and
they didn't have bathrooms
um because there's no way of emptying
them right
so they had a burn pit which i'm sure
you've heard about like jon stewart has
been really
a big proponent of like isn't that
unhealthy
very unhealthy it's given a lot of guys
um very difficult medical
and lung issues over the years yeah
because you're just pooping and burning
and just throwing not just
poop it's like they throw anything in
there that they're not used there's a
trash pit
so whether it's like weapons that don't
work anymore
or oil like i mean
anything that's in there they're just
like uh they burn stuff
and so there's pee tubes all over the
base
um but you know as a woman you can't pee
in a tube like a p tube
and so you'd have to go into a stall and
the stall are just like these like
wooden stalls that have a toilet seat
and you're given a wag bag and so wag
stands for waste alleviation
something and you take the bag and you
put it over the toilet seat and you go
in the bag and you put this gel in there
and then you seal it up and then you
walk it down to the pit and you throw it
in the fire
well when it's full of tea
it you can't throw it that easily like i
would throw it
and the wind would catch it and then i'd
just be chasing it down the base
i did that three times and i kept having
it
closer and closer and closer you know to
where you're just
like you know like you have to you know
get really close to the pit
and so when i get back to the u.s
i i start i get a headache i get a
really bad
headache and i'm like whatever i get
headaches all the time and it's getting
worse and worse and it won't go away
after about a week i've started to lose
motor function i've started to lose like
i'm stuttering a lot
and my hands i can't really like when i
tell my hands to do something they don't
always do it i'm having trouble
walking um so i go
and see my friend work is i don't have i
didn't think i had health insurance at
the time and my friend's
wife worked at this neurologist so i go
to see him and he goes you need to go to
the hospital
right now so i go to the emergency room
he's like
i think you have a minute i looked it up
and i was like i think i have meningitis
was it which is an infection in your
brain fluid and your spinal fluid
and so i get to cedars and they go
what are your symptoms and i go and all
i can get out is i think i have
meningitis and she's just like you do
not have meningitis you know like rolls
her eyes so i wait in the waiting room
yeah so i wait in the waiting room for
like three hours
because i'm being a woman right i'm just
pushing through the pain
you know and um i'm still making
jokes i'm like if i have aids just tell
me you know what i mean
and uh so i'm like
i'm laying i'm finally getting back and
the doctor says why do you think you
have meningitis
and i said well i was just in
afghanistan and
i was around a lot of like pits that
burned feces which and i know that's how
you
can catch it is from any kind of bodily
fluid like being around those
i'm not i'm like i'm single i ain't been
kissing nobody
and uh and she goes what were you doing
in in afghanistan and i was like buying
a house you know like that was like
that's what i always said i was like i
just need three more goats and then i
can get a down payment
yeah so they're like laughing but
they're like no really and i go i was
doing stand-up comedy and the nurse was
like oh my son
is out there he saw a comedian i was
like well if it was a woman it was
probably me
so anyway they they do the spinal tap
they admit me immediately because i have
um i have viral meningitis i don't have
bacterial which i would have been dead
already if i had had bacterial
but i had viral i was you know it had
already gotten into all my fluid
my so that's why i was not able to walk
or talk
and um they admit me immediately and as
they're admitting me the nurse comes
over and shows me a picture of her and
her
my me and her son yeah oh oh it's not
chill
i know yeah so look here's the last
thing before you die
this is where you almost died and that's
why you're here my son said you were
right but april was funny
you're like god damn it yeah oh my god
so yeah so i ended up being in the
hospital same lady that rolled her eyes
no no no no no that was the admission
yeah five days so what do they have to
do they have to like drain the fluid
like what do they do
they just pump you full of antibiotics
to fight it off so
like i was just basically like had ivs
for like five days and like just
um yeah i had to kind of pee it out i
guess or something
i don't remember how they were giving me
all kinds of stuff this is 2011 so i
don't
i don't really remember because i was
also in such a daze you know and i was
alone like
my friend lenny like helped me like
check into the hospital but i didn't
have any family i wasn't like
dating anyone so i just like i had a
couple friends come in
a couple days but i was just kind of
there like hoping not to die
i'm hoping not because my mom was like
freaking out you know
she's like at work but she can't like
get a flight like that and i'm like
don't worry i'm only going to be in here
for a day or two you know and so
but it ended up being a couple more than
that but i was fine
yeah but it did it was like very scary
like looking back it was like it could
have been like
it could have paralyzed me it could have
like done all kinds of things like
as a comedian you know like and i had
gone to a couple hospitals before that
being like
and they're like it's just a cold it's
just a cold and i'm like it doesn't feel
like a cold
don't just listen to your body and keep
going yeah yeah so
i finally looked it up and figured it
out but yeah afghanistan almost killed
me in a different way
yeah yeah that makes you wonder how many
people do die from that
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was that was
just like a really freak like fl you
know fluke axia but that
that was the one i was on with pogitsky
though with christina
and jody miller yeah all moms now
all moms now um something i
i mentioned to you before i always ask
my first time guest
um advice you would give to your 16 year
old self what would you tell 16 year old
sarah tiana
what would i tell 16 year old sarah
tiana
um probably just to have faith that it
will all
work out you know i think you know jeff
garland always
like he gave me the best advice when it
came to this business which is like
because i would always
complain about luck like people in this
this business is a lot about luck
i mean i think hollywood is like the
royal family like it's very rare for a
commoner to get in like
it's very um incestual
a lot of people are born into it and
i was complaining once about uh luck and
i was like i know that luck is just
perseverance plus time and he would be
like
yeah but perseverance is just keeping it
together when nothing is going on
like if you can just keep your mind
right
when you're not busy you'll always be
busy
and so i think about that all the time
and i any time i get
anxious or worried i think about that
and i think i could have saved myself
a lot of heartache in my early all
through my 20s if i had
known that that's great yeah i love you
sarah tiana i love you more
i um i'm so glad you're okay i'm so glad
you're here i'm so glad you're a mom i
know you're going to be such a great
[ __ ] mom
um please you would always tell me that
way before i was away before
way before yeah well please plug
everything again
yeah sarah tiana.com sarahtiana on
twitter and
instagram catbandanna.com for all of
your
dog and cat bowtie needs and bandanas
and shout out to my mom sue haynes who
loves she loves this show
i'm getting you a mug mama that mug's
coming home
um thank you so much for real and uh
thank you all
as well uh please subscribe to the
youtube
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all
next week
you